[Music]  Lauren Conrad just announced she's  expecting her first baby have you talked  with her about that I haven't I haven't  spoken to her in years but what an  exciting time in her life I'm so happy  for her and it's just it's cool to see  the evolution of everybody from the  hills on the go-to beach of course and  to see how everyone is growing up it's  been really fun to watch you just had a  birthday how was that I did yeah my my  30th birthday it was fun my husband  threw me a huge surprise party I was  completely surprised and we're actually  going to Mexico this coming weekend so  yeah my birthday continues I'm excited  how are you gonna be partying tonight  I'm literally gonna go in I'll probably  have one drink and go home and go to bed  I've become such an old lady I'm getting  on a plane early in the morning gotta go  be a mom tomorrow when I get home I  can't be you know any somewhat hungover  at all so I can't do it like I used to